One of our favorite things to eat in the fall time
when the apples are there
peak here in Utah is homemade apple sauce.
And I make mine very simple.
I just core my apples, I leave my peels on,
I put a little bit of lemon juice,
and then we cook that down for a little bit.
And while that was cooking,
we also made apple cider doughnuts today.
So I added all the dry ingredients to one bowl,
and then we added all the wet ingredients to one bowl,
which is melted butter and sourdough and eggs,
vanilla,
and also applesauce is a key ingredient.
So we had finished applesauce at this point.
Miss Wardrobe falling asleep.
We made the transfer, then we added our cooked down apple cider.
Can we combine the wet ingredients with the dry
and you just mix that until combined
so you don't wanna over mix your batter.
And then we made them into donut shapes and got frying them.
I used a beef tallow to fry them in today
and it worked perfectly. They were so fluffy and turned out beautifully.
And then we coated them in some maple sugar and cinnamon.
And that's what we had for dinner today
was warm applesauce and apple cider donuts.
I'm not complaining because it was so good.
It was 10 out of 10. The perfect fall treat.
And my kitchen smelled amazing.
Was like a fall candle in the kitchen. We loved it.